Disney has finally dropped a full
trailer for frozen 2 the sequel will
focus on Elsa search for the origin of
her magical powers here are 12 details
from the trailer you might have missed
[Music]
the opening scene of the trailer shows
Elsa battling against giant tidal waves
thematically it makes sense that also
has a complex relationship with the
ocean after all her parents died in a
sea storm her struggle against the waves
may represent her effort to come to
terms with and better understand her
past
after being plunged under the waves Elsa
finds herself face to face with a water
horse staring at her with glowing blue
eyes
the official film synopsis explains that
this creature is a NOC a mythical water
spirit that takes the form of a horse
who uses the power of the ocean to guard
the secrets of the forest these magical
spirits figure prominently in Norse
mythology which is one of the major
influences on frozen the existence of
the trolls apparently isn't a secret
anymore
since grandpa V reveals himself to Elsa
while other people are present in the
background
Abi's narration references a continuing
theme from the last movie the past is
not what it seems
if his words sound familiar it's because
of a line and let it go the hit song
from the first movie
[Music]
but what does pabbie mean when he says
the past is not what it seems
does it have to do with the origin of
Elsa's powers or are her parents not
actually dead fans have speculated that
one or both of Elsa's parents have their
own powers that allowed them to survive
the shipwreck and that they sent the
water horse as a message to indicate
that they were still alive that
possibility adds an element of mystery
to this shot which shows Elsa and Anna's
late mother Queen Adina while we only
see the back of her head it's clear
she's wearing the same outfit that she
did in the first film and her brown hair
is styled in the exact same way both
this trailer and the teaser released a
few months back
indicate that a significant part of the
movie will take place during fall the
latest film poster also shows Anna and
Elsa in the woods surrounded by fog and
red leaves Elsa's ice palace appears in
this shot at the end of frozen
marshmallow the ice giant created by
Elsa is seen returning to the palace and
crowning himself ruler since marshmallow
is now depicted as a benevolent being
perhaps Kristoff is headed there to seek
out his help meanwhile we see anna
traversing rough waters in a canoe made
out of ice she's traveling alongside the
enchanted snowman Olaf and is actually
using his arm as an oar as we saw in the
first movie Olaf's body parts are
autonomous so they can be broken off or
moved around without hurting him for
years fans have speculated that frozen
sequel will introduce new characters who
possess their own elemental or perhaps
seasonal powers the trailer includes
imagery of the four elements earth fire
water and air since Elsa can create ice
and snow her powers lie within the water
element are there three additional
characters whose powers correspond with
each of the other elements if so whoever
controls wind must have formed those
giant waves that were overwhelming Elsa
and someone else must have brought the
fire that she tries to fight with ice
and for Earth it remains to be seen what
those powers would look like if you look
closely at the four stones you'll see
that a different elemental
symbol is carved into each one the
carving on the left-hand pillar looks
like a blooming flower representing the
earth element this carving is in the
Diamond Lake shape of a snowflake or ice
prism symbolize in water this one
approximates the shape of a flame
symbolic obviously of fire finally the
right hand carving shows what looks like
a rock or round object above three
parallel lines horizontal lines in
parallel are often used to symbolize air
a matching set of symbols appears in
another shot which shows Elsa forming
ice crystals in the sky the same
patterns were even more clear in the
first teaser back in February Josh GAD
who voices Olaf tweeted that the poster
included some major clues it seems like
he was hinting at the presence of those
four symbols etched into the snowflake
design on the poster
[Music]
so did we miss anything let us know in
the comments
[Music]
you
[Music]